bonjour bonjour moi c'est vous savez
quel jour on est aujourd'hui quel jour
l'indiana mardi ces adolescents viennent
de syrie de roumanie d'algérie et de
macédoine ils ont échoué dans le
territoire de belfort
après avoir fui la guerre et la misère
on les appelle des allophones c'est à
dire des mineurs isolés qui parlent une
autre langue que la nôtre alors pour les
intégrer dans un cursus classique ces
jeunes sont d'abord scolarisés dont
cette unité pédagogique afin d'apprendre
le français
je leur apprends ce qu'on appelle le
français la langue de scolarisation cdu
le français de l'école c'est à dire
qu'il y a des consignes qu'il faut qu'il
faut comprendre une consigne faut savoir
ce que c'est se situer sur un plan
montre et pour nous c'est simple nous on
l'a appris on l'a entendue depuis qu'on
a qu'on a six ans mes yeux pas pas
forcément en plus pas avec ce
vocabulaire là le lycée professionnel
diderot est l'un des trois
établissements du département à
accueillir des allophones de juin à août
onze jeunes ont été accueillis ils
seront quinze durant l'année scolaire
2018 2019
les élèves allophones que nous
accueillons et leur nombre ni rabreau
lampard diminuant nous avons un devoir
aussi parce qu'ils ont des besoins
éducatifs particuliers
certains d'entre eux ont été très peu
scolarisés dans leur pays d'origine
d'autres au contraire ont une agilité
linguistique à une maîtrise plusieurs
landes
c'est une ressource que nous devons
valoriser d'ici quelques mois
samir mohamed maher et blanc diana se
dirigeront vers les filières de leur
choix soit à diderot pour apprendre la
domotique ou l'électronique soit dans un
centre de formation professionnelle